este viejo edificio de madera de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial hace las
funciones de hospital de Medicina
familia de pediatría del área chernigiff
por su cercanía Bielorrusia el Hospital
Regional fue bombardea dos veces en
marzo 2022
sigue luchando para que sus pacientes
sean atendidos Aunque medios precarios
la gente nos siguió porque están
acostumbrados a sus médicos confían en
ellos trabajamos y Tratamos de
brindarles una asistencia de calidad
pero las condiciones como pueden ver No
son buenas en este antiguo edificio de
una sola planta consuelo de madera
cuartos y pasillos estrechos solo hay un
lavabo para el personal sanitario
mira este es el único baño
Lamentablemente Estas son las
condiciones con las que trabajamos
Lidia atienden
diarios la sala es muy pequeña y cuando
los pacientes vienen con sus padres no
pueden esperar aquí no hay espacio al no
poder estigmatizada la habitación no
puedes vestir al niño porque hace mucho
frío
echo de menos nuestro hospital
de las familias de sus pacientes hace
que el trabajo del idioma tenga mucho
más valor
Alex pequeño mijael no les importa el
frío la incomodidad el improvisada sala
de espera porque confían en su pediatra
cuando entramos aquí me impactaron todas
estas condiciones no podía creer que
hubieran bombardeado el hospital y que
los médicos siguieran atendiendo pero
quiero visitar al mismo médico para mi
hijo
Así quedó el Hospital Regional uno de la
media docena de instalaciones de
atención médica bombardeada solo en el
inicio de la guerra
al caminar solo los escombros oxxanna
Recuerda que este hospital recibía más
de 45.000 registros hospitalarios el
ataque al hospital de chernijib
representa un crimen de guerra y a corto
plazo pone en riesgo la salud de la
población más vulnerable que son los
niños y los ancianos ante la limitación
de la atención médica por la destrucción
de las instalaciones de salud